Speaker 1: Let's now go to another guy who
should have no business anywhere near the
presidency, Donald Trump.
Donald Trump kicked off his New Hampshire
wing of the presidential campaign with a speech
late last week in that state in Manchester,
New Hampshire.
It was one of the most pathetic speeches I
can recall from Trump doing the woe is me
stuff to a degree I've never seen.
Trump's face, as usual, his right eye almost
completely swollen, shut.
Trump seeming agitated and irritated.
But hilariously he kicked off the event announcing
this is a major announcement.
He is no longer going to use the crooked nickname
for Hillary Clinton.
He is now going to call Joe Biden Crooked
Joe Biden, which is the super creative and
exciting.
But the crowds seem to like it.
Speaker 3: Against crooked Hillary Clinton.
But today I'm going to do this.
And I think this could be maybe the most important
part of what I'm going to say, because this
is going to be a major announcement.
Are you ready?
I will be retiring the name Crooked from Hillary
Clinton and her moniker, and I'm going to
give her a new name.
I don't know, like maybe lovely Hillary or
beautiful Hillary, but I'm going to retire
the name Crooked so that we can use the name
for Joe Biden because he'll be known from
now on as Crooked Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: Just absolutely electrifying the
crowd.
And of course, as you all know, that will
get 6 million more people health care.
So that's really something that is actionable
and important for a presidential candidate
to be talking about.
And this was that was one of the better parts
of the speech, I hate to tell you.
And the New Hampshire crowd, particularly
sycophantic Trump bringing up Kim Jong un,
Kim Jong un, and talking about how great of
a relationship he had with the dictator.
Speaker 3: South Korea.
We take care of their economy.
We take care.
Speaker 1: Of him, by the way, being more
critical of South Korea than North Korea.
Speaker 3: Here we take care of the military.
They're right next door to Kim Jong un.
He and I have a very good relationship.
People would say it's not good to have a good.
Really?
Yeah, it's very good to have a good relationship.
It really is.
But he's not so happy with Biden.
He says bad things about Biden.
But what I really yeah.
Speaker 1: Trump still seems to think that
when dictators like you, it says something
good about you.
Now, of course, the truth is far more complicated
than that.
But this idea that we should be concerned
that Kim Jong un doesn't like Biden if it's
true, Right?
No, we should have been concerned by the degree
to which Kim Jong un felt he could roll right
over Trump.
And I actually recently read the new Bradley
Hope book about North Korea, which I recommend
to people.
And it actually outlines a lot of the ways
in which the Trump foreign policy towards
North Korea, to the extent that there was
foreign policy, rather than just Trump's ego
running everything very much worth reading.
Bradley hopes New book about North Korea.
Now, at another point during the speech, Trump
quotes Lenin and refers to him as Lenin.
And this is another one of these things where
we just don't really know how Trump gets into
this.
Speaker 3: You know, Lenin, Lenin, Did anyone
ever hear of Lenin?
He said.
The vote counter is far more important than
the candidate.
Has anyone ever heard?
That's right.
Lenin.
Lenin, as they say.
As they say in Russia.
Speaker 1: I almost thought Trump was going
to be quoting some lyrics from the great song
Imagine, written, of course, by John Lenin.
But he didn't.
He was quoting Vladimir Lenin there, Trump
seemingly justifying, just not debating in
the Republican primary.
And he talks about how Nixon and Reagan and
Bush didn't debate.
But of course, you know, it was a completely
different situation in that the there was
not actually a primary in those cases.
Listen to this.
And this is Trump starting to pre lay the
groundwork to not participate in debates that
might not go well for him.
Speaker 3: He really helped prevent, say,
bet on the opponent and then they want to.
Do something on the debate.
Of this.
They want a debate.
They want to have I have people at one half
of 1%, one quarter of 1%, 1%, 3%, 2%, 4%,
7%.
And Desanctis is very low and crashing.
He's crashing and burning.
Don't forget, when he came to me, he was at
3%.
So he failed in his campaign.
Speaker 1: He said.
Speaker 3: Sir, you endorsed him, which I
could have done without, but I endorsed him.
And he went up a lot.
But he went up and he won.
But when he.
Speaker 1: Riveting stuff, as you can tell.
Speaker 3: For a long time, he failed.
And now he's failing again because now he's
getting a chance to campaign without Trump,
to put it mildly.
To put it mildly.
But so these debates, you know, Nixon and
Reagan and Bush, Bush number one, others.
No, they didn't debate in the primaries.
Speaker 1: Now, why didn't they debate in
the primaries?
It was because they were sitting presidents
running for reelection.
Of course, the difference is Trump is not
currently the president, although maybe he
thinks he is.
Maybe his followers think that he is.
So there is an open Republican primary.
That's just the reality.
Trump then weirdly turns on one of his earliest
and strongest supporters, Senator Lindsey
Graham, who was recently on TV crying because
Trump needed money.
He calls Lindsey Graham a progressive.
This is a really strange moment.
Speaker 3: It's called reciprocal, reciprocal,
reciprocal.
So if India charges our companies 100, we
charge their companies.
100 is very simple.
And yet we have people in Congress who say,
No, I don't think that's good.
Anybody that says that's no good.
Very interesting.
Lindsey Graham, the progressive from South
Carolina.
Speaker 1: And the crowd boos.
I thought they liked Lindsey Graham.
Speaker 3: No, he's a progressive, but he's
got some good things, too.
Okay.
But Lindsey Graham, I said to him, Lindsey,
you got to go along with this.
We were all set to get it done.
You got to go along with this.
He says.
So let me let me get this straight.
If they charge us, we charge them the same
thing.
He said it's not his strength.
Other things are his strength, he said.
So they charge us.
We charge them the same thing, right?
Yeah.
You got my vote.
That's so easy.
Speaker 1: All right.
So I guess Lindsey Graham, you know, when
I think of your classic progressive, I, of
course, think immediately of Lindsey Graham.
Really strange moment.
Trump did that disgusting anti-transgender
weightlifting routine.
And this really, really, really titillated
the crowd.
Probably the most electrifying moment of the
speech.
Speaker 3: Should
I do it now?
Unidentified: I'm going to do it.
Right.
Speaker 1: All right.
That's Trump visibly straining to lift weights,
which is really one of the favorite thing.
I mean, the crowd was pretty dead throughout,
so that that wound him up a little bit.
Trump did deal with policy, but sort of dealt
with policy by saying he will put in his travel
ban again.
And he mentioned something about you saw that.
Right.
But of course, it's like never clear what
he's talking about.
Speaker 2: Out of here.
And I will.
Speaker 3: Reassure my travel ban to keep
radical Islamic terrorists out of our country.
You saw what happened for years.
For years.
We went for years.
You saw that, right?
We were very tough on that.
We don't want our buildings blown up.
We don't want to have problems to back out
of here.
Speaker 1: So Trump Trump also took questions,
which was hilarious because he didn't answer
any of them.
Here's someone who asked him, How will you
engage with Generation Z voters?
And Trump just basically said, Oh, we're already
doing it.
Like, oh, all right.
Problem solved, I guess.
Speaker 3: Thank you very much.
God bless you.
Speaker 4: My name is Christine.
I'm from Atkinson, Hampshire.
And engaging with young voters is crucial.
Here in New Hampshire, we have American first
warriors like Caroline it.
Right.
How do you plan how do you plan to engage
with Gen Z voters?
Speaker 3: Well, I think we're doing that.
And I tell you what, you would be shocked
like Charlie Kirk and others, the job that
they do with their with their youth.
It's a youth movement.
It really is.
That's another movement.
You would be shocked to see how popular we
are in college campuses.
Much different than what you read.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, we actually have the
election results from 2020 and 2022.
They are not engaging with Gen Z.
And in fact, what's been going on with abortion
is probably only going to turn off more Gen
Z voters.
So a ridiculous speech, but the crowd liked
elements of it.
So that gets us to our next question.
Who goes to a speech
like this?